- I have a dream.
Martin Luther King est un héros
de la lutte contre le racisme
et la pauvreté. En se glissant
dans la peau du pasteur,
Didier Lucien réalise
DIDIER LUCIER, comédien
"Au sommet de la mone"e"e"
- Oh yeah... Mais c'est un rêve
concret, complet et qui rentre
dans la lignéeaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaia.
- La pièce "Au Sommet de
la monta i i imagine Martin
Luther King dans l'intimité
de sa chambre d'hôtel,
la vemememememememememememememel
1968. L'icône devient alors
s s simple mortel.
- Il y a quelque chose
d'intéressant là-dedans, de voir
ces êtres-là que moi-même,
je déifiais, : : : : : : : : : s
sa hambre d'hôtel, il devait
être pas loin de moi non plus!
- C'est sûr qu'ils vont vous
écouter après ça.
- Au fil d'une discussion avecue
la paix se montre vulnérable et
tourmeL'autrice afro-américaine
Katori Hall, qui signe la pièce,
a voulu en quelque sorte réparer
le passé, car sa mère,
avait voulu voir le pasteur
lors de son passage en
CATHERINE VIDAL, Metteur scène,
"Au sommet de la montagne"
la mère de l'autrice, de ne pas
avoir pu le voir e e e e et puis
l'autrice a imaginé, en fait,
la rencontre, l'occasion ratée;
rencontrer dans cette pièce-là.
- Parfoi d d d d demande d'où ça
vient, cette haine envers nous.
- Didier Lucieheheheheheheheheh,
accomplissant un tour de force.
- Ma recherche était pas
nécessairement juste historique.
J'ai rdododododododododododododt
il bougeait, ensuite comment moi
je croyais... comment je voulais
le voir bouger dans cette pièce-
des décisions, des décisions
et des décisions.
Comment on peut essayer
d'envoyer un homme sur la Lune
les enfants qui crèvent de faim
au Mississippi?- - - - - - La pe
d'actualité, car les mots
de Martin Luther King sod'd'd'dl
à la réflexion, mais aussi
à l'action.
- S'il y a un kid dans la salle
qui n'a jamais ehehehehehehehehr
la pièce, c'est intéressant
de faire comme : Ah, peut-être
qu'il va se mettre à lire,
puis er r r r r r r r r r r r r,
puis comment tout ça s'est
passé, et où est-ce qu'on en est
maintenant.
est présenté jusqu'au 26 mars
chez Duceppe.
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Montréa